[Music]
nobody wants to talk to him
and watch the way obama ignores him when
he puts the hand watch this
he knows the president of the united
states is touching him right now
he knows it and just look at that he's
leaning on him
so so
let's let's process this let's process
this from three different angles and i
want to get your perspective on this one
how do our enemies process that so putin
how do maybe you know
and iran a china xi not necessarily
enemy but they're not our allies right
how does
what is barack obama's motive here is he
coming in and saying hello vice
president joe biden and he says this was
part of the skit we talked about it
undermining him
and number three
biden himself is he's sitting there
thinking in his own mind with nobody
telling him this not his advisers not
his peers nobody's saying
i think i may be replaced here right
after november midterms what give me
give it to me perspective from those
three lenses i think it frightens our
enemies because they look at this video
and they say oh my gosh
he has superpowers he can be invisible
and walk around a room this is a
dangerous guy tom this is why you could
only be a comedian around big
universities that have technical minds
but but go ahead what are you doing no i
was a pg orc fan
well first first i will address that but
did you guys see the video from about a
year or two ago we showed it on my show
i think yesterday of obama saying that
what his dream would be to have a third
term but he would just need a dummy out
there and he would just be able to talk
to them in their ear basically he would
just need a body he said that two years
ago i'll send you the video later he
said it about a year ago that that would
be his true dream he would love a third
term where he was the puppet master
he just saw it right there ladies and
gentlemen charlie mccarthy by the way
i'm totally cool with that
if obama is actually running the show
and not biden oh i'm just saying i'm
cool with that oh we do have a little
work to do with you still okay okay
we'll get you you'd rather biden be at
the helm is that where you're no but no
but biden obviously isn't in charge it's
not a question so in essence yes i do
think
which gets to your question oh this is
it this is it yeah um is it suspended
or what is it
yeah i think it might be 16 minutes keep
going i think there's another factor in
this but dave rubin well well first i
would say that biden obviously is not in
charge i think what sort of happened in
that moment is that everyone realizes
how bad all of this is we all know
inflation supply chain
ukraine afghanistan okay all the stuff
right we all know how bad it is we know
the polls are terrible all of that
everyone also knows that kamala was
polling at zero
literally zero in her own party when she
dropped out and then they chose her
quite simply because of the color of her
skin we we see these are she was a black
female
and her genitals yes so
they know that this thing is so damaged
right now
that the other part is that joe biden
has dementia or or something like
dementia he then that is very sad i
don't mean it to be glib or anything
else
i don't think he's going to even make it
between that and now it's coming out
with the hunter biden laptop so i think
the system is now figuring out a way to
push him out the fact that jen saki just
announced this week that she's leaving
to of course go to msnbc so she's the
chief liar paid liar in america and now
she's going to do it just on a on a tv
channel i think the system is shifting
and it's realizing man biden dementia
all the problems and and what obama did
right there was sort of just assert him
he just pushed himself back in and
obviously he's not going to get a third
term in a traditional sense but they'll
let kamala take over
and she will probably just have to kiss
the obama ring and do exactly what
you're asking for which i think will
lead to an awful lot of bad policies
that are just a continuation of what's
going on yeah okay so put a timeline on
it is are they are they are the looming
midterms the last straw or is that their
is that their flash point or their
well look the thing is their convenient
milestone you always have to remember
the machine does crazy things so
obviously right now everyone thinks it's
going to be the crazy red wave right
everyone that's what every pole is
saying everyone's predicting it you know
what kovid magically comes back in
october and suddenly it's male in
balloting and harvest ballot harvesting
and all the blue states and then
suddenly it's not such a wave and then
they can
you know who knows but that it's a game
it's it's a giant game of thrones chess
game that is that is many layered beyond
just what republicans voted 5148 on this
thing
so that that's basically who do they
replace them with though i mean so so
now you then it goes to the bench okay
so the bench becomes what pete buddhich
that's the bench he's gay
good enough who's defense good enough i
think he's really smart guy i don't i
mean he's only run a small town in
south bend indiana why is he the
transportation secretary i don't know
nobody knows the same rights
well yeah they said he's he's the
teacher are you trying to say that
you're gonna be the next transportation
secretary is that what you're saying but
i'm as qualified as pete
i can tell you that his confirmation
hearing was something of a joke yeah uh
well were there vehicles in your town
yeah yes there were is there a bus
service yes
um i'm i'm done with my list senator
yeah no that's it that's nothing there
is nothing to it how do you process this
because you probably well let me just
say this
i think a very number one you're not far
off dave i don't think i'm not willing
to say that biden has dementia but
clearly he ain't exactly all that are
you is anyone at this table confident
that the president of the united states
is cognitively able to be the president
right now and truly making all of the
decisions
i don't think he's making all decisions
i think it's speculation what he has i
don't know
he did he did handle you know his speech
about ukraine and like i thought you
even said that he did a decent job with
that
um it's the best i've seen him do okay
and that was a month ago so every now
and again he can snort adderall and
basically read a teleprompter i mean
that's basically it you know and by the
way why don't you tell them what
happened when you and your husband met
trump what did he do with melania that's
a that's a good story it's really an
incredible i'll try to do this somewhat
quick version of it we go it was the
week of impeachment yeah there was 18
impeachment i was like which one dude
yeah the first the first sham in the
original and remember it remember
remember those two weeks where everybody
everyone in mainstream media the walls
are closing in trump is freaking out
um the whole thing so i heard i was at a
turning point usa thing in west palm i i
spoke and then then trump announced that
he was coming so they cleared out all
these so basically i ended up opening
for him and then for trump he spoke yeah
dude but it wasn't planned that way it
was just that he announced that he was
coming out of nowhere so then so i spoke
he speaks i had never heard him speak in
person before and first so already
something had moved with me that morning
because when he spoke and you see him
speak live and then you read the media
after you can really see the disconnect
so there's a beautiful moment in his
speech where he's talking about wind
power and he's like i know wind power
more than anybody and nobody knows more
about wind than me and the turbines and
he's going on and it's so obviously a
joke it's so obviously just a punk and i
turned to david and i said to him i
guarantee you politico is going to write
a headline or one of that donald trump
says he knows more about when and of
course five minutes later the headline
shows up anyway
uh we see junior there and we become
sort of friendly he says you want to
come to dinner with kimberly and i to
mar-a-lago tonight so obviously we said
yes
we go in again this is the height of
impeachment we're in the you know
there's two rooms there we're in the
smaller rooms there's only about 20
people or so there's trump sitting there
with melania
and rudy giuliani and and one or two
other people
and he has his shirt open really open no
tie first yeah so first off you never
see trump like this right his jacket's
kind of leaning back he looks relaxed
his hair looked relaxed like he's just
and he's laughing and having a blast and
i'm just you know we're not sitting at
the same table but i just kind of have
my you know i'm just looking right
anyway at the end of dinner junior says
hey you want to meet my dad so obviously
yeah i'd love to meet your dad so we we
walk over and and uh the president's
sitting and he says dad i want you to
meet dave rubin um and and he looks at
me and he's kind of he's sitting so he
looks up and he's like i kind of
recognize you i kind of and i was like
oh well i'm on tucker a lot or maybe you
see me outside he says oh yeah yeah that
must be it and then he turns to david my
husband and he goes well who are you
and he goes well i'm his husband and he
goes husband husband
that's great you guys are gay
he goes melania can you believe it these
two guys are gay
he goes
he goes guys let me tell you something
you know what your only problem is
you're too handsome both of you guys are
too handsome yeah that's what he said
and then melania then uh she's kind of
points she's with a friend she's kind of
pointing at david so david walks around
the table to talk to melania and then
it's me junior and trump and then
somebody grabbed junior so now it's just
me and trump and this is also so it's
impeachment and it's also right when
bloomberg got in the race yeah so i had
this moment alone with trump i'm like i
gotta say something that says you know
something so i was like i was like mr
president i just got to tell you my
crazy theory and my theory is
that the machine wants biden because
it's just a vestige of the old thing but
they know he can't survive in the
debates because he's so bad so so
bloomberg is in basically as a decoy
which i really believe is what happened
they threw him in it was never real but
they needed because biden was still
leading they needed all the energy
remember those two debates with
bloomberg it was only about him biden
barely spoke because they knew he would
break down under under attacks
so i tell him this i said it's a
complete decoy bloomberg's not running
it's all about biden and he's he's like
this he's like you know
that's that's something that's something
and then he goes and this also really
changed me on trump he reaches across
the table and he puts his hand on
melania like very gingerly softly puts
his hand on melania and he goes honey
honey listen to this and he said it
lovingly right and the the meme is that
they hate each other or she's a cat you
know kept she slapped what happened at
one time they played it a million times
i'm telling you he did it in the way a
husband that loves his wife would touch
her hand and then he called her honey so
the way he did that so he has me repeat
what i said to him
uh to her
and i say it and she kind of nods and
then he goes nah he just hates me
talking about bloomberg meaning that's
why he got it he just hates me but the
thing that moved me more than the the
gay thing or that silly story
is that he loves his wife it was very
obvious that i told him something
interesting and his first inclination
very interesting very interesting yeah
i've
i've heard him a few times at mar-a-lago
and i got to tell you
the guy could have been a comedian yeah
he's a stand-up he's a stand-up
because there's no cameras he gets up
and it's 90 minutes no script no nothing
any
half the time you're laughing with jokes
and obviously he's trolling i think he's
gonna go all the time as the greatest
troll of all time i think he has the
gold medal for it i think he owes the
guinness book of world record for it i
don't think anyone's going to come close
to him as a troll he's in the league of
his own but what's so impressive about
the whole situation is the fact that
he's about to get impeached a second
time biden could potentially win and
he's just having a good time i'm telling
you let's see this guy shirt open like
this
there was something it was just like he
he that also was when i was just like
all of media it broke down a lot of
things for me that he loves his wife he
didn't care about gays that the media is
just so dishonest it wasn't just the
wind power article that i knew was gonna
come it was just he's freaking out you
know he's in his inner sanctum with his
and it was like no he isn't he's sitting
there laughing his ass off